cleaning the mouth and the nose with
water whilst one feels just like
refreshing the mouth um or in the middle
of
woodu is this a permitted act as far as
putting water in the mouth or goggling
the mouth with water or putting water in
the nose whether a person is feeling hot
or whether while doing woodoo it is
permissible because it doesn't enter the
body as long as the water doesn't enter
the body a person does not swallow the
water it's permissible and in wudu
goling is a requirement putting water in
the mouth is a requirement but natural
doing Woo is f before offering Salah and
while fasting you have to offer Salah
and you have to do wo so how can it be
prohibited so when a person puts water
in his mouth while gaggling in woodoo or
otherwise he should be careful that he
does not swallow the water and when he
puts it into the nose there are some
people who think it will break the fast
based on a
Hadith and that's the reason they only
touch the water to the tip of the nose
and they don't put it inside because the
Hadi of the messenger of Allah subhana
tala and wasallam said it's mentioned in
Hadith of sun Abu da volume number two
in the book of fasting Hadith number
2360 that the prophet said snuff water
excessively while doing woodoo except
while fasting mhm that means the prophet
recommended that you should snuff put
the water excessively in your nose
except while fasting indicating that if
the water goes through the nose into
your throat into the stomach it will
break the fast that doesn't mean putting
water in the nose is prohibited so
normally when you put water it doesn't
go into your throat and even if you
snuff excessively always it doesn't go
it can go so it's a precaution the
prophet said that don't snuff water
excessively while fasting otherwise you
have to do that so this also proves that
putting water in the nose it is
permitted but you have to be careful you
should not snuff excessively so that it
goes into the throat otherwise if water
goes into the throat and the stomach
either VI the mouth or the nose it will
break the fast but unintentionally while
doing woo or while goggling if the water
does enter inshallah Allah will not hold
you responsible because it's done
unintentionally